[Applause]
thank you i appreciate it great to see
you
we were uh thank you
thank you we were off last week in the
words of
ted cruz i'm back what i miss
ted cruz uh good for comedy this guy
proof that [ __ ] can step in itself isn't
it he's just
and i'm not making fun of texas you know
i go to like i used to when i
could travel that may happen again uh go
to texas a lot and
texas is fun but boy i tell you that it
is it is a fun place uh
not used to the cold though there in
texas and men were showing up in the
emergency room with their
lips stuck to their gun terrible
just uh they had a cold snap down there
that you can't believe
on the highway that the truck nuts were
shriveled on the
vehicles it was and ted cruz of course
you know this he went to
he bugged out and went to cancun and
then blamed it on his kids
he said i was trying to be a dad
yeah except when they lower the
lifeboats then i try to look like mom
oh yeah the republican
republican party they are they're
struggling right now they need heroes
because i'm sure you also saw this the
week we were off uh last week
rush limbaugh uh died oh please
hold your tears his legacy will live on
whenever a rube is yelling [ __ ] yeah by
a transistor radio
so i kid rush he's
he's gone now he can't hear me but uh
hey
there's scandals on the other side too
andrew cuomo
in new york you've read about that now
he's got a sex
sexual harassment scandal some woman in
the office says he
shouldn't have flirting i don't know you
know that's what she's
kissing that shouldn't have happened to
jokes that were not good
i know it sounds cheap it was actually
very romantic he said to her i want to
grow old with you
and then put you in a home and cover up
your death
[Applause]
but american politics
it's it's so screwed right i mean these
the crazies
are just an ascendant now right i mean
the the 22 year old woman did you see
this this week who
part of the capital riot who got in
there and stole nancy pelosi's laptop
there's a video now of her dancing to
techno
and giving the heil hitler salute and
that stuff is very offensive but techno
[Applause]
and all the crazies are meeting this
weekend you know what this week it is
for the conservatives down in florida
it's cpac that's the
conservative political action conference
they have it every year it's the
woodstock
of conservatives said oh it is a big
deal for them
all the latest strains of cobit are
going to be there
it's really something and
they have orlando florida is hosting it
they've got a big banner over main
street welcome reality deniers
it's really
and i have sad news to report from that
site uh
our break from having to listen to
donald trump
is coming to an end it was a lovely few
weeks which will be known to
future historians as the great quiet
but um but he's going to be the the
keynote speaker at the end
the final speaker and this is look at
this this was what they were doing in
today
wheeling in the golden calf
boy trump's party is stuck on him like
gorilla glue
aren't they they just love this guy and
i i know what's going to happen he's
going to get up there and say that he's
the nominee
and no one's going to object to this you
know they're already on this page and
he's not going anywhere and he's going
to return
and he's not going he already has a
slogan for 2024. let's get done what we
never started
you